hi everyone my name is justine tan and
i'm with the ibm cloud team
let's talk about ibm cloud pack for
integration
more than ever organizations are looking
to digitally transform
providing their employees with secure
and timely access to relevant data
and empowering them to make better
business decisions
but before they can innovate they need
to connect all of their data and
applications
while at the same time minimizing their
exposure to business and security risks
unfortunately traditional approaches to
integration are slow to implement
hard to scale and requires skill
intensive
complex technologies organizations need
to accelerate integration with a new
agile and ai powered approach
one that offers specialized integration
capabilities
and enables extended teams to create
integrations
leverages a complete set of integration
styles and capabilities
and embeds ai and automation enter
ibm cloud pack for integration a
comprehensive
hybrid integration platform that
leverages ai-powered automation
across the integration life cycle to
improve use cases like
natural language powered integration
flows ai assisted mapping
api test creation anomaly detection
as well as workload balancing in
addition
you can accelerate development of
integrations by reusing assets that are
published to the asset repository
and by leveraging built-in smart
connectors
achieve the optimal mix of legacy and
new system development
modernizing core applications to be
cloud native and
unlocking the value of your data and
services while sunsetting other systems
bringing together the industry's most
complete set of tools and capabilities
and enhancing them through automated
deployment eliminates the expensive
maintenance downtime
and multiple licensing fees that
accompany other vendor offerings
or roll your own approaches with ibm
cloud pack for integration
we've seen companies speed their
integration development by 300 percent
reduce their integration costs by over
33 percent
and increase their overall operational
efficiency
all while maintaining enhanced security
governance and availability
contact us to learn more about how we
can help you build ibm cloud pack for
integration
into your business strategy as always be
sure to subscribe
and stay tuned for more videos like this
in the future